我不知道大家有没有这样的经历啊
就是说想考一个证
资料买了一堆
视频看了一堆
拖着拖着报名时间就过了
有还是没有啊
想换工作
对吧
投简历之前
哎呀想多再学点技能
结果一学就是半年
哎机会没了
还有的同学
总是想写一点什么
想去拍一点什么
做个副业
对吧
脑子里边剧本已经演了几十遍
但是呢迟迟
动不了手
就是想着做一件很重要的事
但这个时候总会告诉自己
哎呀等我准备好了
我就开始
结果这一等
就是好几年
每次行动前
我们总想再等等
再做一点准备
对吧
再看一点资料
咱们再想的周全一点
就是咱们告诉自己
我不是拖延
我只是还没有准备好
但你有没有想过
我们真的是在准备吗？
还是说
我们在用准备的这么一个东西当
来逃避那个我们焦虑和害怕的
那么在心理学上啊
这种反复思考
不断准备
却迟迟不开始的状态
我们把它叫做
它看起来啊
就像是一种
对完美的这么一个追求
而实际上
是被恐惧劫持的拖延
是一种高质量的
那么接下来
我想带你从心理学的角度
来揭开这个
让无数人原地踏步的
这么一个完美陷阱
让你看清它的本质
了解它的运作方式
并且学会与之相处
然后呢
勇敢的迈出
欢迎来到
在心理学中啊
有一个非常有意思
又非常令人警醒的这么一个现象
就是我刚刚说的叫做
什么意思呢？
简单点说啊
就是你总在说
我再准备一下
但这一下
对吧
可能是一年
两年三年
最后一辈子都还没开始
所以你看很多人
表面上
他是在
实则
是在
那在心理学里边
这种行为的核心
其实是一种
那这种认知性拖延
它会来自于这几个地方
第一个地方是什么呢？
那么在哈佛大学啊
有一位心理学的教授叫做
他有一句非常经典的话
他是这么说的
他说
也就是说
我们通过准备
来制造一个我在努力的这么一个假象
你看
很多想考研的人
买了很多的资料
但是一页没翻
却在书桌前坐了3个月
想创业的人
可能你一直在研究这个商业模型
研究了3年
还在调研阶段
想写书的人
资料查了一辈子
第一章还在构思当中
这个不叫努力啊
这个叫做心理缓冲
就是用
在心理学里边
这是一种自我防御的机制
因为每个人都会害怕失败
害怕否定
所以宁愿不断的准备修正完善
也不愿真正的跨出第一步啊
第二个呢
就是你是不是经常说啊
我还没准备好
当你说这句话
你要小心
你可能不是没准备好
而是患上了这种
有一位心理学家叫Linda
他研究就发现啊
完美主义者
他总是希望每一件事
他都能够尽善尽美
但这个标准的本身
他其实是无法实现的
因为完美主义等于什么
你比方说有一个女孩
她准备开始做自媒体
总是先想着我要把文案写到最好
我要把设备买到最专业对吧
我要把我的形象准备到最精致
结果
一年过去了
账号都还没有注册
而另外一个女生
可能随手拍了一个
吐槽生活的这么一个小视频
粉丝破了10万
所以你看
这就是心理学里边的
就是你越想把它准备的完美
越不敢行动
第三个原因
其实我们并不是说
准备这个东西不重要
那心理学里边强调适度准备
而不是无限准备
适度准备是什么？
适度准备是一种
而过度准备是一种
这两个不一样的
那费兰德
他曾用行动
反馈模型
来解释过这么一个问题
他说什么呢
他说
我举个例子
比如说你在家
模拟练习演讲100遍
这个永远都不如你上台讲一次
大家理解吗？
你做了100套的健身计划
不如你现在出门走个5,000步
我上次看那个导演王晶
采访他
他就说他拍那个整蛊专家
就拿到一个大纲就开始拍啦
边拍边写
对不对
结果成了当年票房前五的电影
这个叫什么？
我们再来看几个生活当中的例子
老舍
他写《正红旗下》
花了几年的时间整理素材
但是始终没有动笔
最后没能完成
成为文坛的一大遗憾呐
陈春花的朋友
研究企业管理
有深刻的洞见
但是呢
两年过去了
新书没写
反而别人的书先出了
这两位他不是懒
而是想太多
行动太少
那你看这种
那有三个原因
第一个是什么？
就是你害怕一旦开始就失败
所以干脆咱们就不开始
就是你怕别人的评价不够好
不如先等等对吧
再完美出场
就是你内心深处总觉得自己还不够格
拖着还不敢开始
所以有一位心理学家叫
她就把这种状态
叫做
这么一个
就是我们
理想化了
那么一个准备好了的我
永远存在于明天
而真正的成长
只能发生在今天的混乱
和这种不完美当中
在心理咨询里边啊
我们也经常遇到这样的对话
有的时候咨询师就说啊
你为什么不去报名啊？
那来访者就会说
因为我还没有准备好
那咨询师说
你准备到什么程度才算好呢？
那来访者就会说
我也不知道
我就是感觉还差点什么
这其实叫做
就是把不安
投射到准备这件事上
而不是面对行动的恐惧
说白了
你不是没准备好
是你不敢
面对失败的
那么我们今天说了这么多
那有什么方法可以去应对呢？
解决方法第一个
这是成熟的大脑方式
大家理解吗？
那么心理学的研究表明啊
就是你的大脑喜欢
这么一个模式
那这个就叫做
你要知道
你的行为会激活你大脑的
让你产生我在前进的这么一个动力
所以啊
你并不需要到十全十美才开始
对吧
你看孙少安
没准备好就开了这个砖厂
乔布斯
他不会焊电路板哎
他就开始搞电脑了呀
肖亚文她不会管理公司
就上任了董事长
他们很多人做的第一步都不完美
但这一步
就改变了人生
所以
当我们一直想
不做
你的大脑就会陷入到一种
我们叫做反刍思维的心理状态
那你不断去想
你就越想越焦虑啊
越焦虑你就越不敢行动
而一旦动起来
你就会发现
那些看起来吓人的问题啊
其实也没那么严重了
就像爬山
对吧
你光看地图
你永远都不知道哪一段路最陡峭
你只有开始走了
你才知道哪该喘口气
哪个地方可以加速
所以
成长的秘诀就是
在心理学里边
有一个词叫做成长型心态
那么这是斯坦福大学的一位心理学家
叫
她提出来的
那么她的这么一个核心观点是什么呢？
她说
成功
不是因为你准备的足够好
而是你愿意不断的学习和调整
所以你看
你想开workshop工作坊
你不如先办一期免费的小型班
你去试试看
你想做视频号
你不如现在就拍一个1分钟的短片
你发出去
你想做一位演说家
你不如先去练习一次自我的介绍
哪怕不完美
哪怕有漏洞
那都是真正的成长啊
真正的人生
不是我们准备好了才开始
而是开始了
你才能准备好
所有的大师
都是从新手起步
所有的作品
都是在不断的试错当中打磨出来的
所以我也希望听完今天的这个
大家别再拿
来当借口
你真正怕的
不是事情本身
而是开始之后的责任
但是请记住
心理安全感
并不是你什么都准备好了才有
而是在你不完美的前进当中
逐渐建立的呀